Carlin is with us in Oklahoma City hi
Carlin how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up so I am
following your plan and on baby steps
here with my husband and we recently
welcomed our second child in March yes
well he's the reason that we're calling
at our 18 week ultrasound we found out
he has complex congenital heart disease
and was required several surgeries to
correct that he had open heart surgery
at two weeks old oh well I have another
one yes next or this month or possibly
next month and then another one between
two and three years old your program has
been a life changer for us and we want
to continue to follow your steps we've
paid off it'll be between fifty and
sixty thousand dollars in the last four
years we have one student loan left at
twenty five thousand dollars and so
we're just I know what this makes our
path a little bit different and I just
wanted to see if you had any advice on
how to perceive you concentrate on baby
boy that's how you proceed yeah he gets
everything that just takes your breath
away I mean that just that becomes the
center of your universe right now and if
that slows down or even stops your
progress for a little while well so what
right we got a little go do we yeah we I
mean luckily medical insurance has been
great there's certain things that you
know we're already trying to have to
fight to get it approved and we've been
lucky and had some family help and so we
have got about seventy-five hundred
dollars saved just for the rainy day you
know you need I would push pause on your
Total Money Makeover I'd push pause on
your baby step to your right in the
middle of a storm you're in the middle
of a hurricane okay and just you know
you nail up the boards on the windows
right and you you know you start the
generator and you bring in the water and
you you buckle down and you go through
the storm the good news about storms is
is they don't last forever
right and but you in the middle of a big
one kiddo
yeah and so I what I don't want you to
do is I don't want you to use this as an
excuse to go do something stupid like we
had to buy a 65 thousand dollar van for
this little guy that and going to debt
you don't need to do that the look I can
riding something reasonable I mean you
know but I don't want you to use your if
you're a human being that has a heart
and you're not psychotic this is having
an emotional impact on all of you it has
an emotional impact on me and I don't
even know you're just listening to the
story you know I got a little baby I got
little baby grandbabies right now and I
can't even imagine it just takes your
breath away so I know I mean I can't
even imagine what you're going through
but don't let you know though the the
emotional state give you an excuse to go
do crazy spending of some kind
don't don't lose problem don't lose
progress but I'm perfectly fine well
you're not making any progress for a
while I mean it may be it may be a year
okay before I get so many surgeries
behind you and you kind of learn the
landscape and you learn the rhythm of
his special care and you know all of
that and the rhythm has financial
implications you know every so often
we're going to have a doctor bill that
we wouldn't have had otherwise and
that's not just part of your new budget
but and that but you discover that
rhythm after as the storm passes you're
right in the eye of the hurricane right
now and so just hold tight
don't make don't make any more don't
make any damage don't lane damage occur
to your finances but and again be
careful not to use this as an excuse to
say we were we had to we were forced to
when you start using phrases like that
that's probably not true it's probably
you just got worn down scared and you're
emotional gas tank was empty and you
just bought crap you know people do that
you know it's it's like when somebody
dies they have grief spending you know
that kind of thing it's like it's that
type of a thing so just you know be Oh
be intellectual
aware of that spiritually aware of that
but then as far as you know is this
going to slow down or stop or impede
your progress on your baby steps yes and
it should you should concentrate on the
thing that is in front of you that is
much more important and as we have since
you born we definitely have put a pause
on things we just you know big thing
that resonates with my husband and I is
you know living like no one else we want
to you know take family trips and do
those things and so we don't I know that
when he gets older he does where wants
to here we couldn't do things because of
his condition oh well we don't want that
you know but oh well forever
I mean hey I got a friend that has eight
kids there's things they can't do
because they got eight kids oh well you
know I mean it's just part of what like
it's just life and you know I don't know
if he has to hear that or not you have
to say that but that might be a reality
that you didn't make that you didn't get
to do some things because we took care
of him but hey this is this is the this
is the the blessing that God's given you
is the opportunity to take care of him
and if that means you don't get to go to
art you don't get to go to Florida once
well whoop-dee-do P right of course we
just want to get to the point where we
can you will enjoy eventually but let's
take me let's take a year and live with
this and then you know I think after a
year you're going to have some of the
surgeries behind you and you're going to
have some of the shock of this and
you'll probably discover the rhythm of
life what it's going to look like going
forward and you can start making some
intelligent decisions but again that
that's the cleanup after the hurricane
right now you're in the hurricane okay
so the Hurricanes hitting your house
right now what are you gonna do are you
gonna live there forever no but when the
hurricane passes is life going to be
different yes and you're gonna find the
new rhythm of your new life after the
hurricane passes and you're gonna be
fine long term I'm not worried about
your long term I just want to give you a
permission short term to quit making
progress
okay but don't make dumb decisions
that's the balance okay my mom if I can
help you Don you call me anytime I'm
sorry you guys are going through this
Wow
okay there you go I often get questions
about a family with special it was a
special needs child Kelli our phone
screener talked about it in her debt
free scream the extra challenges they
had to go through and do a debt free
scream with some special needs
situations and the extra expenses that
go with that the extra expenses that go
with that
they just do and that just means you're
gonna go a little slower you're gonna
make more money or you're going to take
the same money you've got you're gonna
make slower progress but you can still
my progress and you can still make wise
decisions and you can still be on a plan
you got to find the rhythm after the
storm and that that's where she is right
now bless your heart this is the Dave
Ramsey show